Hey! Welcome to a new Project Kamp update video!
This video is highly requested by you guys!
We're going to do a review on
our battery powered electric chainsaw.
And, our brush cutter...
You guys have been asking for it,
but we didn't make a review yet...
Because, we want to give a real review,
after really using the tool for a longer period of time.
So, this is one year later.
Both machines are Makita battery-powered,
and just do point it out: we're not sponsored...
We actually tried to remove the brands as much as we can.
Because, we just want to give an unbiased opinion.
And, to make sure we're not sponsored,
or need to say anything.
So, this video, we're going to have a look at them.
We're going to do a contest also between
an electric and a gas powered one.
We're going to test them, and see all the pros and cons.
But, in order to start this whole review,
we need to go back one year in time.
So, in today's update, we have something new.
It's an electric chainsaw.
I never really worked
with an electric chainsaw before.
That sounds kind of impressive to me!
Less noise.
That's the main reason why we have it.
And, it doesn't run on fossil fuels.
So, this video, I want to put it together, test it...
One of few things I'm particularly interested in is:
"How long does it actually last?"
Because, one saw has two batteries,
and I have six batteries in total.
So I can have three sessions, and I'm curious...
To see how long they last before they're empty.
How much noise does it make?
And also, how I don't know how robust
and sturdy this machine feels.
It feels a bit like a toy almost.
It's a small, but important note:
this video is not sponsored by Makita!
We bought the machine
from people supporting us on Patreon.
You might wonder why we did get a Makita...
Basically, because our power tools are already
running on their battery system.
So, we kind of locked into that system,
which in a way feels bad.
Because, you're stuck in an ecosystem,
and might not use the best saw...
But, you just choose it, because it fits the rest.
That, in a way, is also the powerful thing.
Once you have a battery, you can use it on your different devices.
I get it that it has ups and downs...
So, we're going to chop down some bushes,
some trees that I didn't do last time...
Big, small, wet, old, new, fresh...
All sorts of trees.
We have the saw.
Cardboard, cardboard...
The chain.
Chain oil.
The thing that holds the chain.
And, the batteries, which we already had ourselves.
We're going to start off simple, by chopping some dead trees.
I'm not sure if you've seen this...
In Update 3, I made a few pathways right there.
But, I left quite a bunch of bigger trees over there,
because I didn't want to cut them.
Now, I'm going to clean this all up,
and chop them with a chainsaw.
This looks like a good first cut!
That's kind of impressive, actually!
The path is now clear, which went surprisingly fast actually!
The saw itself looks good!
A bit dusty...
The battery life is two dots, whatever that means...
I mean, I'm kind of surprised, actually,
with how smooth this went.
But, to be fair, these are already dead trees.
They burned down a few years ago.
So, in a way, I would say an easy score as well.
For the next part, we're going to the swamp.
Because, a few weeks ago, I cleaned it,
and I took out a lot of trees.
All those trees need to be chopped into smaller trees.
This test is basically to just do a lot of cutting.
So, here are a bunch of trees,
and I'm just going to chop them down.
New batteries!
All right, so, all the wood is now chopped,
which is quite a lot actually.
It went super fast, and super smooth!
Maybe, it's just because it's new, that it's all fun...
But, I'm kind of still surprised how smooth it goes!
Halfway in, the batteries were empty,
so we had to change them.
Just swap in other ones, and it's done.
Also, that's smooth!
Now, the battery's half empty again.
So, I would say doing all of this took me one battery pack.
So, two batteries in total.
Now, we go to the next part,
where we're going to chop just a few bigger trees.
And finally, we have this pile!
You might have seen it in Update 3,
where I make the pathways.
This was such a big pile of just trees,
that I never cleaned it.
I always walk over it, which is far from ideal...
Not proud of it, but...
Yeah, maybe now is the time to clean it up!
So, for this test, we have one full battery.
I'm just going to put on a timelapse,
and chop to see how fast it goes.
And, how much battery it takes,
to get rid of this pile.
So, this job is not finished yet,
and I'm out of batteries...
Now, I did work a bit intensively,
with a lot of thick wood in a very short time.
But, yeah, the job is just not finished yet,
and the batteries are empty...
With a normal chainsaw,
you could just add fuel and continue.
And, with this one you have to recharge...
So, I'll continue tomorrow,
which is perfectly fine for me.
But, if you're in the middle in the job,
I could see that being a bit annoying.
But, for now, since we can't cut anyway,
let's open this one up to see how it's made.
So, a final verdict!
I would say it's a pretty good saw, and nice to work with!
But, I would also say:
"Don't really believe anything I'm saying."
Because, I'm not at all experienced with chainsaws,
and it's the first time I'm using it...
So, obviously, everything is exciting,
and everything is still good and proper.
I think the test is really about time, like:
"Is it still durable after a while?"
Does everything stay properly?
Doesn't the stuff break?
So, I would say:
"Make sure to remind me in a year or something."
To make a review, or to talk about this thing...
Because then, I could give a real honest review about it.
But, I would say: so far, so good.
All right, so, here we are: it's one year later.
This is what this looks like now.
It's a bit more worn out.
We used it heavily, but it still functions as it did before.
I actually forgot to mention the model before...
It's a DUC353, in case you're curious...
And, as we were using this throughout the year,
we actually also bought an electric brush cutter.
because, it's the same battery system,
and we kind of liked working with the electric tools.
So, we got one of these as well.
This one is the DUR369A.
So, I'm going to show you it a little bit as well.
How this one is being used, and whether we like it or not.
Because, we've also been using it for a year.
But, looking back at the footage...
One year ago from saw, I was kind of excited when we got it,
because it felt super powerful.
Quick cuts!
But, that was also because I was mainly
comparing it with a handsaw.
So, yeah, obviously a chainsaw is a bit
more superior than this one.
What I actually needed to do
is to don't compare it with the handsaw...
But, instead, compare it with a chainsaw,
because this is kind of the competitor of this one.
This is a saw we got from a friend,
and we have been using this electric saw.
Both throughout the whole year.
We've been using both.
So, now, we have a pretty good reference
between how they compare to each other.
And, I would say, the main thing that is
different is actually just the power.
This thing has way more power than this one.
Let me actually show you in a little contest,
if we're going to use this one, compared to this one.
To see what the difference is.
So, here we have our setup.
Here we have one big log!
We chopped in the middle, and then we put in like this.
So, this side is exactly the same as this side.
We're going to chop them
with a gas saw and an electric saw.
And, we're going to see which one is fastest to start.
How long can they cut?
Which one cuts the fastest?
So, we're just going to start,
and you guys can see how it's going to be.
You can count.
- When we will start?
Three, two, one!
I had a biscuit that rolled away!
12 and a half!
When you have a super sharp thing,
also in the beginning, it cuts super slick.
But, if it's not very sharp,
it cuts not good at all.
And, this one still cuts...
- They seem pretty similar.
Now, the only way to settle this is a battle!
And then, we just gear up, and we will cut this!
Right, so, the winner is this one!
Tim got 13 slices, and I cut nine in the same time.
My battery is almost empty as well,
so I would have to stop soon or Tim could continue.
So, yeah, let's say this one has a bit more power.
Now back to the review!
Okay, so, here we have the pro and con of this machine.
The pro is that it's quite quiet,
compared to the gas-powered machine.
So, soundwise it's much less.
It's also much easier to start.
You just press a button, and you're good to go!
With the gas saw, you have to pull the cord a few times.
It also depends on the motor, if it's hot or cold.
So, yeah, it takes a bit more effort to do.
Which makes it, as a third pro, very friendly to use.
Especially, people here that haven't
worked much with a chainsaw.
This is much easier to just grab,
and you take it and you cut something.
And, finally, it just doesn't use any gas,
and it's just a kind of magical!
It just runs on electricity, and in our case, it's solar.
So, in a way, it's just free energy flowing in
You can use it as much as there's energy available
The downsides on this saw.
It's empty quick, and runs on two batteries.
But, once the batteries are empty,
you have to recharge them.
And, this takes a while...
Meanwhile, you can't do anything,
unless you have more batteries.
It's not as powerful...
We've been mainly chopping young, fresh trees here.
Which are kind of easy to cut, compared to a thick old tree.
So, it's good to cut some basic little things.
But, if you really want to cut a lot,
it's a bit challenging with this one...
And, it's also hard to fix.
Like, mechanically, parts like the chain are the same.
And, the locking mechanisms.
But, the whole motor is all electrical driven.
So, if something is broken, you can't fix it.
Like, with a combustion engine,
you really have to bring it to Makita.
Where they can change it or replace it.
So, those are the differences a bit,
between the two types of saws.
But, they actually also have a lot of similarities!
Both have a brake, both have a handle,
both have a chain and a mechanism to cut...
And, both also need to use the chainsaw oil.
Actually, one little tip on that,
you also have this thing called biodegradable oil.
Which I would recommend, and it seems nicer,
if you cut it in the middle of nature.
I would also have one extra other tip,
in terms of sharpening the chains.
So, you're going to need to sharpen the chains,
after using the chainsaw.
And, usually, you do this with a file,
so you go over the teeth and you sharpen it.
But, there's kind of an art to it,
and especially in this setting with us.
Where multiple people use the chainsaw,
you don't want one person to clean it all the time...
But, learning how to clean a chainsaw
can be quite challenging.
You need to have the angle right,
to make sure you sharpen it.
So, we also discovered this tool, which we like a lot actually.
Because, it sort of explains how to sharpen it.
This thing defines the angle.
So, it makes sure you put it perpendicular to the chain,
and you always go in the right direction.
You make sure it's horizontal.
And, it also chops down this smaller part here,
in front of the chain.
Which you usually wouldn't even sharpen with this one.
But, every now and then you also need to do that,
to really make sure the chain sharp.
So, this tool does all of that.
It's very easy for people that are not
very experienced with a chainsaw...
To sharpen the chain after using it.
Just a little tip: if you work with multiple people,
I would recommend this thing.
Okay, so, that was a rough review for chainsaws.
Next, we're going to go quickly over to brush cutter as well.
A lot of similarity, but also a few differences.
So, let me show you.
All right!
Here, we have the brush cutter.
It looks pretty similar to a usual brush cutter,
as with the chainsaw, except this one works on battery.
It also slides in two batteries.
The same as the chainsaw.
And then, you have three different speeds that you can use.
We've been using this one for over a year as well.
We've done a lot of rough things with it, I would say.
A few complications with it as well...
Here, the plastic cover broke.
I would say it's on us, because probably some stone
or something chopped in there...
It doesn't really seem to be the issue of the machine.
However, we did have two electrical issues as well.
One was right after we bought it,
and one a few weeks ago.
It then just gives an error.
You can't really do anything, besides bringing it to Makita...
And then, it was a nice again,
as it came back a few weeks later.
But yeah, that were a bit of the downsides...
And, for this machine, it works also pretty similar,
as the usual brush cutter.
So, you have a few blades you can use.
Let me actually show those!
So, when we first started brush cutting,
you had all these different kind of blades...
We didn't really know what they meant,
or how to use them for what purpose.
So, I'm quickly going to show you.
Because, I think is very useful information,
when you start brush cutting.
So, we have a string cutter like this,
with a little nylon cord.
It's good for chopping grass.
But, the moment you want to chop something thicker,
this breaks, which is not ideal.
It also leaves plastic around...
So, you need something bigger.
What we like to use is this triangular blade.
This is kind of an all rounder.
It's good in just chopping and it can chop thicker things.
It's also good for mulching, so you can really make,
whatever you're going to cut, small.
So, it could chop grass, but also more like brambles.
Like, bigger things.
If you really want to cut a lot of brambles,
which we've been doing a lot, like big bushes above you...
You can use a blade like this,
with the blades going downwards.
Because, you can really go from top to bottom,
and it sort of chops everything underneath there.
It's a bit more aggressive to use,
but very effective for thick brambles.
We recently had it inserted with this blade,
It feels very rough to me!
It's just a circular saw blade,
and just spinning there in front of you.
I guess, I'm used to working with tablesaws,
where everything is very fixed and safe with perfection covers.
And, here you are, just swinging with the blade!
But, this made me used to chop more
smaller trees and branches in front of you.
So, you can just sort of have a saw in front of you.
Just chopping the things...
The blade we use mainly is this one,
because a bit of an all-rounder.
You can go to things like grass,
but also thicker bushes.
It sort of just chops!
And, we also like to use this one,
if we really take on big brambles.
The blade itself, the saw blade: I don't like it...
This one every now and then,
if we really do the grass.
But, yeah, this is just standard information for brush cutters,
but just not specifically for electric ones.
So, now, let's get back to why
this electric one is different than a gas one.
All right!
Here, we have to review of the brush cutter,
with the pros and the cons.
They're very similar to the chainsaw,
as in, it's also less noisy, because it's electric.
It's easier to start, and it doesn't use any gas.
So, you can just run it on electricity, which is cool.
And, the downside is that it's also hard to repair.
It can really open it up, and it doesn't last super long.
The battery life, and the sort of endurance is not very high...
However, the main difference is that it does have enough power.
It really feels it's good, unlike with the chainsaw.
So, those were the two reviews
of the brush cutters and the chainsaws!
Now, let me give you a final verdict,
of both of these electric machines.
All right, here's the final verdict of these two machines,
used for one year in our setting.
So, a big plus for us is that they just make less noise.
Because, we're here with many people in this land,
so we easily disturb each other...
The less noise they make, the better!
Second one: it's quite friendly to use!
Because, you don't need to deal with the gas,
the starting, the hot or cold engine...
Also, the moment you don't use it,
you don't have to have it run idle.
You can just turn it off and turn it back
on again, when you need it.
Which makes this whole process much more friendly,
than with the gas-powered device.
I mean, it's running on solar,
which is the main reason why we have it.
We're here off-grid, so we can just use the electricity
and we put it directly in the machines.
It's kind of magical, and they're
pretty good to just quickly do something!
Because, you just pick up the machine, and you can start.
You don't have this hole start-up,
like the gas-powered machine.
Now, two main downsides:
I would say the chainsaw is a little bit of a joke...
It's if you really want a chainsaw for bigger trunks,
or a lot of them.
It's nice here and there, but if you really want a chainsaw,
for multiple hours in a row...
I wouldn't recommend this thing.
The brush cutter has less of this problem.
It feels like it's really made for a job.
But, the downside that both of them have
is that they consume quite a lot of batteries...
For us, it's less of a problem, because we have already this
whole Makita system with a lot of batteries.
But, if you don't have that,
you need to buy a lot of batteries.
To make sure, that once they're empty,
that you can keep going and keep swapping them.
And, besides that, the charging just also takes time.
With the gas one, you can just keep on going all the time.
You might need to wait for your batteries to be charged...
Besides that, I would say: nice machines to have!
I, personally, really like to brush cutters, because it's just smooth,
compared to a gas powered one to work with.
Quickly start-ups, quickly stops! I like it!
The chainsaw is nice to have around, but I notice myself,
every now and then, I still use the handsaw.
If I want to just cut something smaller.
And, if it's thick, it's still too small for that...
But, that's just my personal opinion!
But, yeah, that was a review of our electric saws!
That's it! Potato time!
All right, so, that was it for the review video!
Now, I am sharpening the chainsaw.
Something you always have to do after using it.
And, if you like the review, let us know!
Because, we could make more reviews like this in the future,
on whatever tools we are using.
Next week, we're probably going to continue
renovating the ruin again!
We take out some big pieces there!
If you already want to see that video,
make sure to support on Patreon!
So, you can see the video one week ahead.
If not, we'll just see you again next week,
at the same time and the same channel!
Thanks for watching! See you next week!